hi there steve kaufman here um i am
going to get back to the subject of
language
uh study and i think the next thing i do
on language will have to do with
the
continuing in my view greater importance
of vocabulary over grammar and when i
struggle speaking russian it's words
that fill me not grammar in fact if i
get the endings wrong i don't really
care
because i can still be understood
but if i can't find the words that i'm
looking for then i'm in real trouble but
today i want to talk about the
copenhagen conference because it's on
now i think
um it's in the news all the time and
sort of just ramble a bit i've got all
my thoughts worked out yet but talk a
little bit about how i feel about this
conference why is there a conference in
copenhagen well first of all let's
recognize that for a lot of people who
go to these conferences they like going
to conferences there are all kinds of
government departments
that that's their lifeblood that's their
work preparing for these conferences and
they get to travel there and they don't
travel economy
and when they get there they don't stay
in the ymca or in the local youth hostel
it's a great time
uh so i think that's number one
a good chance to get together and and
justify all this taxpayers money that's
going into these things
and there's different agendas there you
know um
certainly
uh the climate could be the climate is
changing because climate always changes
so that's a fact
um
man-made co2 emissions uh undoubtedly
influence the questions undoubtedly but
i'm convinced that they do influence
climate change
uh what are the
consequences of this we don't really
know
um great arguments about who's going to
be a winner and who's going to be a
loser
the
water levels around the maldives islands
have
you know risen and no they haven't
uh
co2 is
increase is causing desertification
deserts and deforestation yet another
report shows that forests are growing
faster particularly in the
warmer climates i mean there's so much
conflicting information i can't make
head or tail of it what i do know is
that the people
probably people on both sides are
completely unreasonable that the people
who are pushing the panic button
are out falsifying information
they treat anyone who disagrees with
them as a a heretic
uh
you know very much reminiscent of the
kind of uh atmosphere that there was in
in the totalitarian
germany or or you know stalin is russia
there's only one party line anyone who
disagrees with it is evil
uh to be eliminated and the ends justify
the means and and and certainly within
the sort of uh
the global warming
um
tribe
there's a lot of the sort of
anti-capitalism anti-west it's bad
industrialism is you know
industrialization is bad and i don't buy
any of that and of course inevitably
there's a lot of these sort of
anti-capitalist anti-globalization
people demonstrating and making a big
nuisance of themselves i mean the fact
of the matter is as i've said before
here we live much better today than we
ever did before everywhere
including in the underdeveloped world
the proof is that there's so many people
living there you know
yeah we have altered the ecosystem we
have altered in a way that favors humans
because it used to be that maybe there
are only a million people living on the
planet a million humans another seven
billion so something there must be good
for humans or there wouldn't be seven
billion of them and there are these
extreme environmentalists who say that
that's bad for the planet well i don't
care i mean the planet will survive the
planet will adapt you know uh
we have a situation in british columbia
where there's a massive attack of the
mountain pine beetle
well that's bad for the trees
bad for the forest industry but it's
good for the mountain pine beetle
they're doing really well and as they
have periodically in the past although
some people are saying it's caused by
global warming well then why did the
outbreak take place in the north and
it's now moving south
uh you know where it's warmer it started
where it was colder
i don't know whatever happens to the
environment it'll benefit some species
and not other species my interest in
thing is in things that benefit the
human species obviously in the long term
not in the short term
and i think
that we could finesse the whole issue
if we simply address the fact that we
shouldn't be depleting non-renewable
resources when there are renewable
resources available why aren't we
burning all the garbage to make power
there's a tremendous amount of
biomass out there but it's not
economical to use it so obviously the
price of energy needs to be raised and i
don't believe the alarm is to say that
that will cost millions of jobs and
cause our um economy to come to a
grinding grinding halt it didn't happen
when oil went from five dollars a barrel
to 50.
so let's just double the price of
electricity we'll have to pay more for
it but then it'll be bring on a lot of
renewable energy resources and maybe
make wind power more economical and
solar and a number of other things and
stop arguing back and forth about
global warming and pretending and hiding
information to justify this position or
that position it's just i mean i'm in
the forest industry we plant trees we
plant trees not because we think it's it
costs money to plant trees and tend the
forest
but and and there's no return on it i
can't justify it i'm not going to be
here we live in we operate in the
northern boreal forest the trees take 90
years to grow
i won't be here in 90 years and if i
thought of investing money for 90 years
i wouldn't plant trees because i have no
idea what they're going to do with trees
in 90 years from now it's just a cost we
take trees out we put trees back in so
there should be some kind of attacks on
non-renewable energy usage
another agenda here at in this
copenhagen conference is the whole idea
that somehow the west is bad because
they have caused the problem of co2
emissions but the fact the matter is
that the population in the third world
has grown
tremendously this past century has grown
much faster than in the bad west and
it's done so because of the kind of
technology and the kind of medical uh
you know advances that have
come out of out of this the
industrialized world
which no longer is just the west because
japan is very much part of the
industrialized world so is korea so are
parts of china and parts of other
countries parts of the middle east parts
of africa and so forth
and you know we will find ways to live
within
the means of the resources that that we
have available to us we used to have 80
of the people on the farm and now it's
like three percent in the developed
world and they produce too much in the
way of agricultural products
uh the whole idea that somehow the west
now owes it to the developing countries
i don't buy that it's like this whole
thing about the africans trying to claim
compensation for slavery i mean get
serious i i don't know i did in
tremendous detail but i suspected what
happened when the europeans went to
africa they went there looking for trade
and so what are they going to trade
they're going to trade what the local
market has to offer
and in indonesia spices in africa it was
slaves why were slaves available it's
not because the europeans went charging
around the jungle looking for slaves
it's because that was the product that
the local merchants were offering them
because slavery wasn't invented by the
bad western colonialists slavery has
been around since the beginning of time
and as long as there were wars people
were taking
slaves and trading them and it was a
commodity in those days and those were
the values that prevailed at that time
and it was the west that put a stop to
slavery and long after that slavery
continued in the ottoman empire and in
the arab world and in many other places
so
i mean history is history things happen
one group beats up on another group not
very nice uh in
all continents in latin what used to be
i mean mesoamerica different groups were
at war with each other taking slaves it
was the same in africa in asia
so i i think that this whole
anti-western
anti-capitalist agenda that seems to be
bound into the whole global warming
thing doesn't help the cause but it's an
opportunity people jump on this just
like al gore is making all kinds of
money uh pretending to be a profit of of
greenism
and this whole cap and trade thing is
going to spawn a whole group of
profiteers are going to jump on this
just like those bankers devising all
kinds of clever schemes
to parasite off money that other people
generate with with genuinely productive
enterprises so
my take on all of this is it's just
another example of
all these bureaucrats living high off
the hog traveling around the world
that we should finesse the whole thing
by saying we shouldn't be depleting
non-renewable energy resources and you
know that's not only good green uh
philosophy it's good for my business
because i'm in the wood business so use
more wood capture carbon in your
buildings with lumber
let us use biomass to make energy raise
the price of electricity and that's it
for now thank you